gargantua fut élevé et éduqué de 3 à 5
ans selon les dispositions prises par
son père dans toutes les disciplines
qu'il convient il pas ça ce temps là
comme tous les petits enfants du pays
autrement dit à boire manger et dormir à
manger dormir et boire à dormir boire
ils mangeaient bienvenu ce soir à sailly
dans le sud de la touraine pas très loin
de chinon territoire gastronomique par
excellence
et pour découvrir un écrivain truculent
une sorte de maître dans l'art justement
de la gastronomie à la française
il s'agit de françois rabelais dont je
viens de vous lire un extrait du
gargantua nous allons tout de suite
découvrir la maison d'enfance de
françois rabelais ici à celui bien mieux
la dernière maison d'enfance de françois
rabelais
[Musique]
donc nous sommes dans le logis du 15e
siècle le gie du père de françois
rabelais donc antoine rabelais qui était
avocat royal à chinon et qui possédait
une maison rue la lamproie à chinon même
donc été la maison de ville et la maison
la devinière qui était la maison des
chambres dites maternité puisque les
enfants de la famine et c'est dans cette
maison semble-t-il
la devinière est effectivement nommés-
parfois maison natale de rabelais une
maison d'enfance ou préférent ce terme
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya toujours
l'incertitude sur la date de naissance
de rabelais cette incertitude elle tient
au fait que nous n'avons plus les
registres paroissiaux donc qu'il
permettait d'avoir une source
je dirais tangible une de sa naissance
donc il ya plusieurs dates de naissance
qui sont donnés il ya 14 ans 83 94 donc
nous sommes toujours dans cette forme
d'incertitude sur la naissance de
rabelais autant que l'incertitude sur la
fin de rabelais c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas de tombe
de françois rabelais qs dire qu'il est
temps les catacombes souparis avec les
millions de parisiens qui l'accompagnent
aujourd'hui donc le mystère sur la
naissance et puis une tombe
improbable
alors la devinière contient une cave
impressionnante qu'on appelle souvent le
ventre de la maison et cette cave
détermine également l'activité qui avait
lieu dans ce lieu est souvent une
activité viticole très importante et
donc cette métairie produisent un vin le
piot le rabelais va célébrer dans son
oeuvre se piot rencontrer dès la prime
enfance va certainement avoir une
incidence également sur le choix de ce
liquide pour en faire un liquide de
savoir à l'équipe de science donc si
nous perdons le vin nous perdons tous
censés loi écrit rabelais et on remplace
le vin par le livre et nous avons le
vrai message ramené un message de
métaphores voilà
[Musique]
merci alain lecomte pour cette visite de
la devinière alors on est à l'extérieur
juste devant le logis on a le paysage de
ce sud touraine au xvième siècle ce
qu'ils étaient semblables d'abord ce
paysage et puis est ce qu'il y à une
infection de françois rabelais pour ce
territoire précis alors le paysage était
sans doute un peu différent de ce qu'on
a l'habitude de voir aujourd'hui mais ce
paysage a été aussi re tram et voilà
quelques années avec la plantation des
vignes près de la maison avec la
création d'un sentier d'interprétation
et donc on retrouve je dirais des traces
d'un paysage qui pouvait être celui du
xvième siècle et ce travail a permis
également le classement comme paysages
remarquables qui est en cours
aujourd'hui donc l'affection de rabelais
pour ce paysage je dirais qu'il est
nettement exposées dans ses romans de
gare seconde phase se déroule dans ce
cadre là dans ce paysage assez
exceptionnel donc avec la bid saillie
donc il habille de frère jean des antes
honneur avec le château les coudes
vraiment pensé qui fait partie des
récompenses que gargantua là offrir à
l'un de ses lieutenants
et puis c'est le point de départ c'est à
dire que c'est d'ici que par le roman
pour se terminer dans le cinquième livre
avec un retour au pays natal avec le
temple de la dive bouteille c'est dire
que les héros ont fait leur parcours
leur parcours initiatique leur voyage et
et donc son parti de la devinière pour
revenir à chinon avec le temple de la
dive bouteille avec l'oracle de la dive
bouteille mots de trink buvait alors
justement un dernier message peut-être
une citation votre rabelais à vous il
dit quoi aussi en sans conscience n'est
que ruine de l'âme je pense que c'est
une bonne une bonne citation qui dans le
contexte actuel que nous vivons doit
être à chaque fois pensé et repensé
merci alain nous comptons petite saillie
donc ce soir s'ils sont gargantua et
demain nous nous retrouvons en vendômois
avec pierre de ronsard les amours